[Musique]
thés lipton politique bonsoir et
bienvenue dans l'hebdo politique votre
rendez vous de dimanche soir sur radio
sensations en association avec tv sont
18 épisodes 212 mon invité ce soir est
le porte parole d'eric zemmour jean
frédéric poisson
[Musique]
les taux politique
jean frédéric poisson bonsoir bonsoir
vous êtes le président de via la voix du
peuple et vous soutenez la candidature
d'eric zemmour à l'élection
présidentielle de 2000 22 vous avez
commencé la politique avec christine
boutin vous avez longtemps travaillé
avec elle comme collaborateur puis
directeur de campagne et enfin directeur
de cabinet vous devenez en 2004 le maire
de rambouillet en intérim de gérard
larcher entrée au gouvernement et vous
devenez entre 2007 et 2009 député des
yvelines en tant que suppléant de
christine boutin elle aussi entrée au
gouvernement vous êtes réélu ensuite
député en 2012 sous l'étiquette ump le 9
juillet 2013 vous devenez le nouveau
président du parti chrétien démocrate en
2016 vous vous présenter à la primaire
de la droite vous terminé sixième avec 1
115 % des voix et vous soutenez françois
fillon au premier tour pour 2022 vous
avez décidé d'abord de vous présenter
directement puis finalement vous avez
décidé de retirer cette candidature pour
soutenir celle d'eric zemmour alors
pourquoi est ce que vous avez fait ce
show pour deux raisons la première c'est
que j'ai toujours annoncé clairement mon
attention
je crois que la france peut se redresser
je pense que le peuple français a tous
les atouts et toute l'énergie nécessaire
pour ça mais je pense qu'il lui faut
pour cela un projet politique qui soit à
caractère conservateur c'est à dire
qu'ils acceptent l'idée qu'on voit
recevoir de nos des générations
antérieures et que l'on ne doit pas tout
ignorer ou foulé aux pieds ce qui s'est
fait avant nous
j'ai clairement dit en annonçant la
candidature il ya presque deux ans
maintenant un an et demi à la
présidentielle que si jamais il se
trouvait un candidat qui portait un
projet politique de cette nature et qui
était mieux placé que moi je me rangerai
naturellement derrière lui parce que
j'ai pas vocation à être candidat pour
être qu'en dire on est candidat à une
élection présidentielle pour porter un
projet politique un certain nombre
d'idées s'il ya des gens qui n'est pas
retenu que vous plus loin que vous la
lucidité et l'humilité aussi consiste à
se ranger derrière cette personne et à
l'ailé c'est le choix que j'ai fait et
la deuxième raison elle est très
naturellement lié
la première
je crois urgent de réunir l'ensemble des
personnes de bonne volonté qui partent à
ce projet politique et je milite depuis
maintenant près de cinq ans au
rassemblement de toutes ces personnes
dans une offre politique homogène et
dans une structure politique la plus de
mots gêne possible les deux se profile
donc très naturellement j'ai rejoint la
campagne eric thébault alors il vous a
désigné porte-parole de la campagne quel
rôle est ce que vous allez jouer et bien
comme son nom l indique de
essayer de faire connaître le projet que
porte eric zemmour et faire connaître un
peu mieux les raisons parfois les
nuances d'ailleurs que ma présence à ses
côtés peu peut faire valoir on peut peut
être expliquer ou dire et puis
participer activement à cette campagne
enfin je suis sur votre plateau ce matin
parmi les raisons mais mais c'est pas la
première fois que je viens et merci de
votre invitation
j'anime des réunions publiques enfin on
nous tournons un rythme aujourd'hui de
deux ou trois par semaine et voilà c'est
d'une campagne coûte en tout cas très
active nous rencontrons beaucoup de
beaucoup beaucoup de gens intéressés par
ce projet
et donc un porte-parole sert à ça c'est
un relais naturel du candidat parmi les
soutiens à la candidature d'ali zemmour
il y en a certains des républicains
guillaume pelletier notamment il ya
aussi certains ralliements du côté du
rassemblement national gilbert collard
ou encore jérôme rivière ont récemment
annoncé leur soutien et puis récemment
l'actualité il y à marion maréchal-le
pen qui hésitent vous l'appelez à
rejoindre la candidature d'eric zemmour
je suis surtout respectueux de son temps
de décision il se trouve que je connais
bien mario que j'ai vu est encore
quelques jours nous avons évoqué ce
sujet mais ma réputation et celle d'une
tombe vous le savez et elle ne sera pas
démenti aujourd'hui donc je respecte
surtout le temps de ces décisions je
pense qu'effectivement ce serait un
atout formidable pour la campagne d'eric
zemmour et pour notre campagne et pour
nos idées que marion nous rejoignent
étant donné ce qu'elle représente et
l'impact qu'elle a dans l'opinion
publique évidemment avant de rejoindre
la campagne d'eric zemmour vous aviez
votre projet c'est lui de 2 via la voix
du peuple que va-t-il devenir
le soutien à eric zemmour
alors il est assez largement partagée
avec eric zemmour en tout cas sur les
sujets régaliens
on va certainement y venir d'ailleurs je
pense dans la suite de l'interview moi
je plaide pour je prône une société
d'entr'aide je pense que ce qui manque
le plus aux français aujourd'hui c'est
de effectivement se trouvaient dans des
circonstances dans lesquelles la la
solidarité active se renouent dans
laquelle on est plus attentif à son
voisin pour l'aider que pour lui hurler
dessus je suis très frappé de voir
comment les relations entre des
personnes se sont tendues depuis ces
derniers temps il ya un effet de la
crise sanitaire c'est certain mais cette
évolution était déjà présente auparavant
entre le milieu des entreprises dans
lequel je suis rentré il ya maintenant
presque trente ans comme jeunes
professionnels et puis solides des
entreprises que je côtoie maintenant
comme consultant parce que c'est mon
métier par ailleurs
est ce qu'il s'est passé entre les deux
eh bien il s'est passé
l'importation en quelque sorte de
d'énormément de violents de brutalité de
violence dans les rapports sociaux et
qui est je crois le la grande faiblesse
de la société française donc mon
objectif c'est de faire en sorte qu' on
puisse plus naturellement plus
facilement plus efficacement avec des
moyens adaptés venir en aide les uns aux
autres et que ça soit le projet
politique que nous partageons pour cela
il ya des décisions à prendre sur le
plan régaliens il y à des décisions à
prendre sur plan fiscal il ya des
décisions à prendre sur le plan social
il y à toutes les politiques se
déclinent mais le but c'est vraiment ça
d'avoir de retrouver le sens de la vie
commune et le sens du partage c'est ça
qui me c'est ça qui m'intéresse quel est
selon vous le thème le plus important de
cette campagne présidentielle c'est une
piscine alors c'est à la fois un thème
est plus qu'un thème c'est la question
de la civilisation alors c'est ça c'est
un mot avec beaucoup de syllabes donc je
sais que sur un plateau c'est compliqué
d'employer des mots évoquent aussi la
plus
prosaïquement là encore ce qui me frappe
dans les réunions publiques que j'anime
aux côtés d'eric zemmour ou en son nom
quand j'évoque
la crainte que partagent beaucoup de nos
concitoyens de voir ce qui leur
appartient c'est à dire la france avec
un grand effet tout ce que cela suppose
disparaître
dans certains cas même on constate que
cette disparition et des sous nos yeux
prenons l'exemple de le patrimoine
industriel
nos auditeurs connaissent certainement
ces entreprises que je vais citer
alcatel technip alstom saint gobain sont
des noms qui ont résonné dans nos
oreilles pendant des décennies parfois
d'un siècle elles sont parties ces
entreprises a été vendu la plupart du
temps à des fonds de pension étrangers
qui maintenant font la loi dans notre
économie ce sentiment de dépossession
économies qu'il vaut sur le plan
culturel il peut valoir parfois sur le
plan territorial il vaut sur le plan
culturel ils peuvent avoir son plan de
la langue des champions de l'histoire
avec le gothisme toutes les
fables pour pas dire les bêtises qu'on
entend sur ces sujets donc ce sentiment
de dépossession
c'est ça qu'il faut arriver à
contrecarrer et donc reprendre
possession de notre destin c'est ça
l'enjeu et je pense que la seule
question de l'élection présidentielle au
fond c'est celle là ça va d'ailleurs
jusqu'à des choses très concrètes pour
nous quotidiennement notre système de
retraite on commence à entendre que
l'union européenne va nous forcer à
adopter un système de retraite qui
serait pas forcément exactement ce que
souhaiterait des français portant
notre système de protection de santé on
commence à dire sur les plateaux sans
rire ah oui est-ce qu'on va continuer à
soigner les gens qui sont pas vaccinés
est ce que
ce qu'ils vont pas devoir payer leur
sang qu'est ce que c'est que ces brèches
qu'on met dans un système qui est notre
modèle social et qui nous appartient
pourtant donc voilà ce qui est en jeu le
reprendre possession destin pour
protéger ce que nous avons de plus cher
c'est à dire nos traditions et notre
mode de vie l'un des thèmes forts de la
campagne d'eric zemmour c'est
l'immigration vous souhaitez stopper les
flux avec plusieurs mesures dont la
limitation du droit d'asile à une
poignée d'individus parents en 2021 près
de cent mille personnes en avaient
bénéficié selon l'office français de
protection des réfugiés et apatrides
vous souhaitez mettre fin aussi au
regroupement familial et mieux
sélectionner les étudiants étrangers
alors que permettront toutes ces mesures
pour les français
d'abord le fait que nous ajustions les
flux migratoires aux besoins de
l'économie française et aux besoins de
notre population
le préalable de ce que vous évoquez qui
est parfaitement juste
c'est que eric zemmour dit une chose
simple français on va d'abord s'occuper
de l'intérêt des français on va
commencer par ça et quand on sera
correctement occuper de notre intérêt
bien on pourra voir ce qu'il en est de
l'intérêt des autres parce que il ya un
moment où si on s'oublie soi même on
peut pas rendre service aux autres donc
commençons par le commencement
régulant les flux migratoires faisons en
sorte que ceux qui sont vraiment en
situation de demander l'asile en france
évidemment ils l'auront c'est à dire
ceux qui viennent pour des raisons parce
qu'ils sont persécutés parce qu'ils sont
poursuivis parce qu'ils vivent sous des
régimes dictatoriaux parce qu'il ya des
motifs politiques les demandeurs d'asile
viennent pour des motifs politiques cela
bien entendu sont les bienvenus en
france moyennant qui remplissent les
critères d'admission et d'entrer sur
notre territoire c'est notre tradition
il n'est pas question d'en changer ce
qui et c'est ce à quoi il est question
de mettre fin c'est le détournement de
cette procédure faire des gens qui
viennent pour d'autres raisons je dis
pas qu'il faut pas légitime je comprends
très bien qu'on n'y a rien à manger chez
vous vous allez chercher à manger
ailleurs c'est ça je comprends ça mais
parfaitement pour autant la mécanique
d'entrer sur territoire français ne doit
pas être systématiquement oui bien sûr
venez chez nous vous êtes bienvenus
d'abord parce que ça n'est pas équitable
à l'égard de nos concitoyens et
deuxièmement
je sais que dans des vies d'enfants un
peu moins content dieu merci
mais beaucoup de nos auditeurs
connaissent les conditions dans
lesquelles porte de la chapelle
sous le métro aérien qui passe par
barbet stalingrad et qui fait tout le
nord de paris à d'autres endroits à
l'entrée autrefois et encore pas très
longtemps de l'autoroute a13 sur le
périphérique à la porte d'auteuil ça
vous voyez des conditions de vie des
personnes qui viennent de ces pays
étrangers qui rend sur terre et et qui
sont indignes on ne peut pas dire aux
gens venez en france c'est merveilleux
c'est formidable vous y vivrez comme des
dieux enfin franchement vous avez vu ces
conditions de vie donc je préfère dire
avec eric zemmour n'ont
personne n'entrera en france il ya pas
un motif proportionnée pour y entrer le
corollaire dont on parle pas souvent
d'ailleurs et c'est dommage parce que ça
fait partie des choses qui des deux
pieds
il faut bien sûr renouveler notre
coopération avec les pays d'origine des
migrations je comprends encore une fois
que ceux qui meurent de faim daoui son
veulent aller dans un pays même s'il
n'est pas très bien où au moins ils
demandent d'inler passants la question
est donc comment est ce qu'on fait en
sorte qu'il puisse avoir à manger là où
ils sont qui ne sont pas obligés de
partir pour aller chercher un sort
meilleur donc c'est ces deux jeux c'est
le chambre oui il faut retenir des flux
migratoires car nous n'avons plus la
possibilité d'accueillir de manière
supplémentaire des migrants sur le
territoire d'eau qu'ils viennent
mais soyons actifs en termes de
coopération et de renouvellement
domaines de coopération avec les pays
d'origine de l'émigration vous souhaitez
aussi durcir les conditions de
naturalisation on en compte environ
75000 en 2021 quelles nouvelles
conditions faudrait-il selon vous pour
devenir français
il n'y a pas d'amour dit malraux il ya
que des preuves d'amour
si vous voulez devenir français il
faudra montrer par votre engagement
personnel que vous aimez la france
apprendre notre langue vous engagez à
respecter nos us et coutumes et faire en
sorte que évidemment vous soyez le 1er à
respecter ses doigts et d'une certaine
manière a
exercé par votre comportement ou à
montrer que vous êtes reconnaissants
à la france de vous avoir donné
l'appartenance à la communauté nationale
donc ce sont des choses qui sont d'ordre
culturel comportementale et plus
seulement un acte administratif voilà
c'est la grande différence avec le
régime qui existent aujourd'hui en 2022
le budget de la justice a atteint les 8
9 milliards d'euros dans votre programme
une fois que vous étiez candidat vous
souhaitiez l'augmenter à raison d'1
milliard supplémentaire par an pendant
les trois prochaines années aujourd'hui
la justice manque de moyens selon vous
c'est un réel problème oui il ya
énormément de service public qui enfin
le problème des services publics en
france par bonjour comment trois phrases
france c'est que
il est doté d'énormément moyens mais qui
sont affreusement mal répartie c'est à
dire il ya beaucoup de moyens là où on
ne comprend pas très bien pourquoi il en
faut beaucoup
et il ya très peu de moyens là où tout
le monde voit bien que il en faudrait
bien davantage sur à une meilleure
gestion oui je prends un exemple très
particulier il ya dans les inspections
académiques
départemental des personnels
administratifs
de manière très conséquente alors je dis
pas qu'ils travaillent pas je dis pas
qu'ils font rien de la journée je ne dis
pas qu'ils ne servent à rien je dis
simple ils font ce qu'on leur demande
puisqu'ils sont payés pour ça c'est
parce qu'ils le font mais je me dis que
ces personnes là elle serait
certainement
plus utile si on les affecter à des
tâches dans lesquels on a véritablement
des gros bang l'administration de la
justice est dans une grande souffrance
qui explique les délais de traitement
devant les tribunaux c'est que la
machine administrative judiciaire le
traitement administratif des dossiers le
fait de remplir les pièces d'envoyer des
courriers
elle ne tourne pas parce qu'elle est
c'est trop volumineux donc il faut
donner des moyens de traitement
administratif
et simplement faire en sorte que dans un
pays où il ya plus d'actes qui font
qu'ils obligent ou qui conduisent nos
concitoyens saisir la justice pour
quelques raisons que ce soit il ya
davantage de gravité d'un certain nombre
de cas on sent très bien que
l'augmentation des incivilités de la
délinquance la complexité de notre vie
quotidienne
tout ça provoque un recours accru à la
justice si donc vous ne donnez pas les
moyens de suivre ça en termes
administratifs
c'est très compliqué l'embouteillage
auquel nous assistons est exactement la
conséquence de ça donc il ya des
mécaniques qui dépasse la simple
question de la justice mais qui met en
cause de statut en général des
fonctionnaires d'état de mobilité plus
facile entre les filières et
d'incitation à le faire et puis il y a
les moyens à donner au monde carcéral
tout le monde voit bien que nous
manquons de places de prison qu'il faut
en construire j'ai changé d'avis sur ce
sujet de lire au fil des années je
pensais que au point de départ ceux qui
voulaient construire des places de
prison c'était pour se dédouaner de ne
pas améliorer les conditions d'existence
de ceux qui sont détenus aujourd'hui et
qui vit dans des dans des circonstances
qui sont insupportables pour beaucoup
d'entre eux ce qui n'est pas bon ni pour
eux ni pour nous et puis je vois bien
que l'augmentation encore une fois du
nombre d'actes délictueux écrit 1000m
nécessite cette construction la voilà je
crois indispensable effectivement
d'augmenter ses moyens dans ce sens vous
souhaiter abaisser la majorité pénale de
18 à 16 ans avec eric zemmour et
suspendre les aides sociales pour les
parents de délinquants mineurs alors
vous pensez que ces mesures permettront
de réduire cette délinquance alors sur
l'abaissement de la majorité pénale à 16
ans oui ça me paraît encore une fois
compte tenu de l'évolution de la
criminalité
et encore et tout le monde voit bien
enfin c'est simplement le fait de
prendre en compte une réalité qui change
sous nos yeux et s'ils ne modifions pas
notre manière de la traiter évidemment
nous on nous la subiront encore
longtemps
nos auditeurs et aux téléspectateurs
connaissent bien où on entendu parler en
tout cas de la fameuse ordonnance de
1945 qui est le régime pénal sous lequel
on traite les criminels et délinquants
mineurs
ce texte de 1945 et voter oui en tout
cas il est décidé dans un contexte
sociologique et criminalité dont vous
compreniez très très bien qui n'est
exactement pas celui d'aujourd'hui 77
ans plus tard enfin le monde a changé
entre temps c'est tant mieux d'ailleurs
et la criminalité y compris des mineures
depuis la même du tout donc il faut
ajuster en fonction de ce qu'on constate
de la gravité dans sa tombe de faits qui
sont commis par des bars des mineurs qui
ont parfois moins de 16 ans
encore une fois ici dans des yvelines
dans notre région d yldune en tout cas
quand on va vers le nord c'est un peu
plus compliqué du département mais par
ici on est on est un peu moins touchée
qu'ailleurs on va dire ça comme ça enfin
des cités ou des endroits pas simplement
des sites est d'ailleurs mais des
endroits dans lesquels des enfants
mineurs portent des armes à feu ou des
armes blanches toute la journée et
participe à des trafics de tous genres
ça existe quand même cette fonte ne
parle pas des choses qui sont des
inventions ou d'élus bidon donc il faut
ajuster sans sur la suppression des
allocations pour les familles d'enfants
délinquants c'est un des points de
désaccord que j'ai avec eric zemmour je
le dis très clairement je n'ai jamais
été favorable à cette mesure
je suis moi même issu d'une famille qui
a été fracturée par la crise économique
quand j'étais adolescent j'étais un
décrocheurs scolaires extrêmement
performant très énergique
si mes parents avaient dû au nom de ce
que j'ai fait quand j'étais petit ça
voire supprimées en plus les allocations
familiales alors qu'ils étaient déjà
tous les deux chômeurs je sais pas ce
qu'on serait devenu donc faut faire très
très attention à ça les la vie des
familles est compliquée les adolescents
d'aujourd'hui sont tout aussi compliquée
que ceux d'hier d'avant-hier ou du
moyen-âge mais
ils ont un climat il ya un contexte
extérieur dans lequel il est tellement
facile tellement facile de partir en
vrille de 2,22 de faire n'importe quoi
d'être un site et un truc un acte qui
change votre vie en quelques minutes
voilà je ne suis pas d'accord avec cette
mesure nous parlons d'actualité
internationale à présent elle est
marquée par les tensions grandissantes
entre l'ukraine et la russie alors votre
candidat eric zemmour et est réputée
pour ses positions plutôt pro-russe
pourquoi faudrait-il
être pro russe dans ce conflit alors il
il faut d'abord être pro russe parce que
les russes sont des alliés de la france
nos auditeurs savent bien que
la france et les états unis jeu viendra
suis juste après la france et des états
unis dans l'histoire sont les deux
seules grandes puissances à n'avoir
jamais été en guerre l'une contre
l'autre
avec toutes les autres nous a fait la
guerre sans exception
la russie aussi mais dans le contexte où
nous sommes
nous avons besoin nous français de
trouver
en asie au proche orient dans l'est
l'europe
des alliés qui nous permettent de
continuer d'être comment dire des
protégés de ce qui s'y passe d'une
certaine façon dans ces régions qui est
souvent désordonnée
j'observe que dans le combat contre
l'islam conquérant la russie est un
allié objectif
je suis pas sûr que les américains
soient aussi allier que ça la proximité
la porosité qu'il ya entre les intérêts
américains et le financement d'un
certain nombre d'officines qui sont
devenus ensuite des officiels islamique
ou ou comment dire la très grande
proximité comme celle de la france
d'ailleurs avec des états qui
soutiennent parfois même le terroriste
est est un problème et je pense que
comment dire nous avons aussi besoin par
notre faute nous nous sommes mis dans
cette position de faiblesse nous avons
aussi besoin de pouvoir profiter de
l'approvisionnement énergétique en gaz
du gadin par exemple qui est fourni par
la russie donc pour toutes ces raisons
il ya aucune n'y a pas de motifs de se
fâcher avec la russie et par ailleurs
je crois pas une seconde que la dmr
poutine est suffisamment idiots pour
envahir les pays baltes d'ukraine et que
les mouvements de troupes armées
auxquelles on assiste pour l'instant
font partie des gesticulations
du théâtre d'ombrés de la diplomatie ce
sont des raisons ils sont en train de la
diplomatie pas de la guerre train de se
passer c'est enfin sur lui la france a
pris pour six mois la présidence
tournante du conseil de l'union
européenne
alors déjà à ce que c'est un sujet
important pour ic vous et est-ce que
c'est l'occasion de parler plus d'europe
parce que qu'est-ce que vous attendez de
cette façon ça devrait être l'occasion
d'en parler davantage au moins pour deux
raisons la première raison c'est que
s'en est ajoutée une troisième
d'ailleurs qu'il a dit hier
pour trois raisons la première c'est que
sur les cartons d'union européenne dans
les cartons d'une européenne il y a le
projet d'un pacte migratoires
qui va conduire à ce que soient
formalisées dans le courant de l'année
2022 je sais pas exactement à quelle
date il est prévu de le faire
le fait que chaque état membre de
l'union européenne sera obligé
d'accueillir un quota de migrants sans
doute proportionnel à sa population
quoi que décide par ailleurs le
gouvernement de ce pays quoique veuille
son peuple et quelle que soit sa
situation
ça devrait nous alerter parce que si
c'est ça enfin vous comprenez très bien
que la sphère six passes en biélorussie
khaimah money beaucoup plus grave que ce
qui se passe en ukraine
tous les flux migratoires qui viennent
de l'afrique tout ce qu'on évoquait tout
à l'heure sur le contrôle des frontières
et ce2 ça va être très compliqué sinon
impossible
deuxième élément
ce profil là aussi du point de vue
européen l'instauration d'une taxe
particulière sur la part de chiffre
d'affaires réalisés par les entreprises
grâce à l'outil numérique personne ne
parle de cette taxe c'est dommage parce
que là aussi elle est dans les clous et
quand on vous dit développer le
numérique développer le numérique vous
avez l'impression que vous allez pouvoir
développer votre activité votre chiffre
d'affaires votre rentabilité
tranquillement mais non vous allez être
rattrapé par la patrouille de bruxelles
qui va vous dire monsieur 12% simplement
parce que bon c'est une nouvelle taxe on
est en train d'installer une taxe
européenne c'est une première et le
problème c'est pas de rembourser le
fameux la rameuse d'être évidemment pour
rembourser la fameuse dette dont on ou
non ne vous inquiétez pas bodjona les
moyens de la rembourser
rien du tout c'est dans l'histoire la
création de la première taxe européenne
de l'histoire ni européenne c'est pas du
tout anodin cette affaire parce que je
vous rappelle que seuls des états
souvent sont amenés comment dire en
principe à lever l'impôt ou alors dans
le périmètre dans le temps le périmètre
de leurs compétences judiciaires des
collectifs des enlève mais avec
l'autorisation de l'état troisième
élément
la présidente de la commission d'avant
der leyen a fait une déclaration hier
qui a qui a certainement dû vous
intéressez sur le contrôle social
et alors je me permets simplement de
d'interroger nos auditeurs et les
téléspectateurs
est ce que à sa tante d'entre eux sont
favorables au projet européen
probablement puisque la france concède
l'opinion française d'utiliser après
parme pour moitié sont des vents
est ce que dans la vision qu'on vous a
vendue de l'europe
il y avait à l'origine le contrôle
social à la chinoise
sans doute que non et sans doute que si
vous aviez compris qu'on irait dans
cette direction vous auriez eu à l'égard
de l'union européenne un peu plus de
distance critique voire une forme de
rejet et bien
je vous renvoie je me permets de
renvoyer ceux qui nous écoutent et qui
ne regarde au discours de philippe se
gare devant l'assemblée nationale sur
traité de maastricht il ya trente ans un
des plus beaux discours qu'on n'est
jamais prononcé à l'assemblée nationale
tout est dedans tout est dedans la
mécanique totalitaire du contrôle social
est inscrite au coeur des traités
européens voilà la thèse de ceux qui
combattent l'union européenne par
l'europe l'union européenne telle
qu'elle est faite maintenant parce qu'on
arrive enfin à voir quel était le projet
initial le fait de contraindre vous moi
tous les citoyens des pays d'europe à
devenir simplement des consommateurs qui
se taisent qui dépensent leur argent et
qui vont travailler pour en gagner c'est
tout ce qu'on nous demande ce n'est pas
la vision que j'ai de l'europe et de la
france non justement elle a carrément
vous souhaitez une europe des nations
comment est-ce qu'on pourrait y arriver
à ce que cela est possible en l'état où
il faudra une réforme plus large de 2
millions européenne il faut certainement
d'abord changer le comportement des
acteurs
c'est-à-dire
exemples récents je fais partie de ceux
qui sont extrêmement critiques à l'égard
de la gestion de la crise sanitaire par
le gouvernement d'ailleurs on en voit
les résultats c'est pas voilà c'est
quand même pas spectaculaire
[Musique]
qu'elle est une des conséquences la
conséquence à mon avis la plus marquante
encore une fois sur le plan de notre vie
politique de cette crise sanitaire c'est
le fait que et bien ça y est on est pris
la décision semble-t-il ou en tout cas
elle est très très avancé de confier à
l'union européenne
la compétence de la gestion de crises
sanitaires sur terre et sur un
territoire français en disant ça sera
mieux fait sur le plan européen
on n'est pas assez grand pour
ces la peine d'aller chercher quoi le
des finances parce que c'est l'union
européenne qui paye parce qu'il nous
donne quelque chose qu'on n'a pas pour
non je crois décidément que ce réflexe
qui consiste à se retourner
systématiquement
vers l'union européenne quand on a
l'impression de ne pas savoir faire ou
quand on a la flemme parce que le pire
dans tout ça c'est une question de
paresse
si si vous gérez la crise sanitaire
correctement si vous dites la vérité aux
français depuis le début si oui voilà ce
qui va se passer on sait pas tout on
tâtonne 11 mois j'aurais compris ça
merci me j'aurais compris mais mais là
là là c'est quand même un peu un peu
fort de café donc merci beaucoup jean
frédéric poisson a aussi terminé major
était avec nous c'est déjà terminé dans
les deux politiques rappelle que vous
êtes le porte en elle des cases et
mouret le président de via la voix du
peuple nous on se retrouve la semaine
prochaine pour un nouveau numéro de
l'hebdo politiques ont invité sera alors
daniel cornes alba le maire de l'étang
la ville très bonne soirée à tous
[Musique]
les politiques